so wait the show takes place in vegas so
are you much of a gambler
do you like gambling well it's a good
thing i don't live there
okay that means you do hit me baby yeah
wait do you like blackjack yeah
blackjack um but i hear um i hear um not
only gamble though but you've hit up a
few interesting strip clubs this is true
i've only been to thunder from down
under myself
i took my sister there embarrassed the
hell out of her oh my god when we were
shooting watchmen in atlanta
tim blake nelson who was just brilliant
on the show he decided he wanted to take
me to this there's a famous strip club
in atlanta called the claremont
lounge i think it's allowed the
claremont and it's in the basement of an
old hotel
and it's famous because all the
strippers
with one or two exceptions are in their
like 70s
and maybe careful i'm close i must
i must go i mean like one of them just
i mean bless their hearts oh my god
you're getting up i'm so excited
like this one girl she just kind of go
like this she was like this oh she like
she was late 70s
with a really short skirt and then she
just kind of like put her top down for a
second
hey i have so many questions but my
first question is
why was he like this is where i'll take
jeans
[Music]
you